USA TODAY's Sam Amick here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Sam Ridge doing
great my friends just the athletic these
days that I appreciate oh my pleasure
good to see you here then very good so
Sam let's start with the with the story
coming out of Houston all right is is
Carmelo done is he done in Houston yeah
I think so I mean by all appearances by
all indications it's messy you know it's
not every day that you see daryl morey
there GM come out and address something
publicly like you did yesterday and to
me it just spoke to the complications
that come with having Melo on your team
in 2018 I think you know because you
know Darryl is well aware that there's
so much respect around the league in the
player community for Carmelo but he's
also aware that this is a team that
unabashedly in the preseason talked
about championship aspirations and that
that was the bar that was the goal and
nothing less and so it's desperate times
and obviously they are shaking things up
already as they've seen you know the
melo thing not worked and overall the
collective approach not working like we
thought it might okay
so as for you said the respect in the
player community it's not just any
players Dwyane Wade and LeBron have
chimed in on Twitter overnight Dwyane
Wade with some words basically saying
trying to make my guy Carmelo Anthony
the fall guy home and you all need to
stop that's the easy way out instead of
addressing what the real problem one of
your compadres in the NBA Twitter or NBA
media world and Tim Reynolds said
Carmelo deserves better and both Dwyane
Wade and LeBron James retweeted that
what what what are they saying Sam can
you can you translate I mean I don't
know what they're saying because I you
know the deserves better part you know I
don't know publicly its you've got the
GM out there saying that it's unfair
that you know the media is focusing so
much on this I don't know who honestly I
don't think anybody truly deserves blame
when it comes to the way it's being
handled I don't think the Rockets are
doing anything wrong by realizing that
Melo is not playing well and not fitting
in well and I think that you know the
reality
and this is you know where I'm always
guilty of being pragmatic and and just
trying to understand things when they
didn't bring trevor ariza back is that a
bad move in a vacuum sure except that
economically based on where they were ad
with the luxury tax you got to tell me
that you think Trevor is worth cutting a
check that I forget if it was like sixty
million dollars something like that
based on what it would cost the
organization so that was a challenging
business decision
newsmen Bob would say is the other guy
who they lost he had shoulder problems
you know I can actually understand why
the Rockets did what they did but but
it's off the rails now and now I think
the danger for Houston
rich is that they've worked for years
and years to make sure that NBA stars
thought that they were a good place to
to be and that they did respect the best
players in the game because as you
remember there was a time when Daryl
Morey had this reputation that's kind of
the emotionless tough to relate to
executive who you didn't necessarily
want to play for he's changed that and I
think right now you you're seeing him
trying to make sure that that doesn't
you know this doesn't change the optics
okay so then what's your best guess who
they're referring to is it the coach is
it harden I mean who are they're
referring to is it is ami mooring with
it I don't - I can't speak for those
guys I think honestly if I'm in their
shoes I think they're just taken up for
their guy and I think they know the
optics that it does look like you know
they're making mellow out to look like
the scapegoat and maybe you know I mean
if I had to guess they probably are
looking at Daryl I just don't
necessarily agree with them you know the
D'Antoni thing is obviously really
tricky we all know the back story that
the time in New York didn't go well and
and really it seemed like you know
Mike's coaching career was going to be
going down a dark road at that point
because of the conflicts that he had
with Melo stylistically you know he
wanted a plan was a stretch for Melo
didn't want to do it they just didn't
mesh well so I don't know who they're
kind of you know taking aim at
specifically I just think that these
guys are brothers to Melo they are
extremely tight with him and it's not
even just a banana boat crew I just saw
Damian Lillard was you know saying the
same thing saying you gotta keep some
respect on Melos name but you know I
don't know I just think it's hard
for those guys to see his name kind of
get dragged through the mud like this
but he's not playing well and he's not
the same guy he was a few years ago so
if he's bought out and sent sent into
free agency if you will Sam can LeBron
go and grab his buddy
in the same way I know obviously Tyson
Chandler's a much better fit as we've
seen with them not losing since
acquiring him what do you think I could
see it yeah I mean it's funny because I
was in the Lakers locker room two nights
ago when they rolled through Sacramento
and this story was just starting to
surface I even talked to a Lakers
official just casually about it and the
idea of you know what do you think Melo
maybe wearing the purple and gold
sometime soon and you know and the
conversation didn't go any further than
then kind of all both of us stating the
obvious that you know that LeBron Melo
connection is front and center and if
not there then we're because we've
already seen you know Magic Johnson's
willingness to put as many you know
characters in that locker room as
possible and Melo in that regard and I'm
not even trying to be flippant with it
but in terms of just taking calculated
risks with you know players that other
places have given up on who you might
think still have some value and are
worth gambling on he would fit and you
know it would you have to Luke Walton to
see does it fit does it fit well and if
it's not fitting well then you got to be
willing to to move on down the line so
but I don't know if it's gonna be there
or somewhere else I know Brooklyn once
mentioned by another reporter as well
but uh yeah we shall see well maybe he
and Dwyane Wade could talk about it when
the Lakers play the heat and a couple
Sundays there you go there you go never
know okay Sam a mica the athletic here
on the Rich Eisen show how close was
anybody other than Philadelphia to
acquiring Jimmy Butler how did that
trade go down best you can tell not very
close on the New Orleans thing that kind
of you know that we learned late in the
process was was interesting but it
didn't involve drew Holliday which you
know that Minnesota has certainly wishes
that it would have and I think maybe the
pelicans get the deal done if they put
you on the table but you know that
obviously was not something they wanted
to do Houston in the end has the strong
opinion yeah I mean you you know they
are involved in everything
all the time if there's a star player
they are pursuing him but as they
reflected on you know their inability to
get Jimmy
they definitely feel like they were used
as leverage when it comes to the talks
between Philly and Minnesota and you
know and that's just kind of how the
game is played and so they put the four
first rounders on the table that wasn't
real appealing to Glen Taylor the Wolves
owner for obvious reasons you're talking
about
takes very late in the process because
everybody you know thought that the
Rockets were going to keep winning games
also other scenarios with Eric Gordon
and na and a couple of firsts that were
part of the process but this Philly
package I really do think they did they
did okay you know what I mean that the
t-wolves adding Sarich adding covington
i think they fit better than you know
some of the other names that were part
of the discussion but philly was the
team that was laying in the weeds they
had pulled out of it weeks and weeks ago
and as of Wednesday I was told
essentially kind of put there
take it or leave a type offer on the
table and then the Wolves had to think
about it and then you know that game
against the Kings obviously with a
tipping point it was so ugly one five
road trip you know Jimmy's play really
inconsistent that night so many weird
vibes around the team and they kind of
grabbed that deal off the table so when
it all comes down to it Sam with the
Warriors tonight taking on the Clippers
without Steph and without draymond Green
who do you think has the best chance in
the West to be this year's Rockets to
use potentially an injury an injury
marred stretch for the Warriors to
leapfrog them in the standings should
that at all be feasible what do you
think right well I mean the crazy part
is that all of a sudden I mean somebody
in the West obviously is gonna try and
try to take that Rockets role but the
East have it you know I'm getting a lot
more interesting maybe the finals would
be more compelling than they have been
last couple of years but if I got a pick
a team I mean I'll probably give it to
Utah you know they've been inconsistent
early on but I love their formula and
and you know that's a team now that with
Donovan in the second year Rudy Gobert
you know becoming you know reigning
these kinds of player of the year and I
love their coaching staff and you know
they're gonna probably do something at
the trade deadline in February to
they've got a very
a forward-thinking front office so the
Jazz is you know if you ask me which
kind of programs I trust the most it's
probably Utah interests um and you know
beyond that there's compelling teams out
there I mean Denver's looked great so
far
Portland's won four in a row and they
come in and take on a Lakers team to try
and send the Lakers hurtling back to 500
on Wednesday that's right that I think
they can do and they probably will do
I'm not buying the Lakers yet I'm the
decent team I'm not buying them as being
able to push back against Portland and
the Blazers on the one hand I give them
a kind of credit you know I did a long
interview with Damian Lillard going into
the season where you know I always
believed in Damian and his like fabric
and fiber I just kind of looked at the
rest of the roster and I saw like coming
off a sweep against New Orleans in the
first round last year I had a hard time
processing that idea that it could
really bounce back and be a top-tier
team again and they've done that they
look great but matchup wise you know the
Warriors I mean the Warriors give
everybody fit the rosters are the Bucks
are the Blazers roster is just not built
well I don't think in relation to the
Warriors so I don't see them as a
Rockets type of threat at all the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience